clearly unjust what the IDF has been
doing to the Palestinians because
there's a vast disparity between the
number of Palestinians being killed and
the number of Israelis I mean I would
certainly hope that Israel is killing
more this isn't a conflict this isn't a
conflict this is one-sided ethnic
cleansing again I'm just asking you if
based on the numbers more Germans died
than Brits in World War II did that mean
that British the British were wrong in
World War II because they did many more
Germans died than Brits based on the
numbers that mean that Britain was wrong
in World War II Britain was bombing
civilian
civilians the people of you should talk
to you should talk to the people in Dres
in but you can't because they're
de